[Musik]
der hat zehn sie
überall auf der welt
und gleicht
rund um die uhr
filmen kameras
packende
extrem ruhig bleibt ruhig
furchterregende
naturphänomene was sollen wir tun guck
dir das an man ist wie gelähmt
es gibt kein entkommen
das ist reality tv sie glauben sie
kennen das wetter diese experten
erklären was wirklich passiert das
wasser fließt in den wirbel mit
den spektakulärsten wetter videos der
welt
vom weltraum aus betrachtet sieht der
planet erde ruhig und friedvoll aus
doch zoomt man näher heran wird die
ungestüme kraft der elemente sichtbar
[Musik]
august 2011 unweit der belgischen
provinz stadt hasselt hat das open air
festival pukkelpop soeben seine pforten
geöffnet
obwohl regen vorhergesagt wurde strömen
65.000 menschen auf das gelände
die leute waren gut drauf und dachten
wahrscheinlich es würde nur ein
gewöhnlicher regenschauer werden doch es
kam anders gegen 18.15 zieht ein
gewaltiges gewitter auf das hagel regen
und stürmische winde mit sich bringt
gefährlich wird es als erste von den
umstehenden bäumen abbrechen und in die
zelte geschleudert werden
wenn du im freien bist also ohne feste
wände um dich herum gibt es keine
sicherheit
sachen fliegen durch die gegend und
tausende von leuten können nirgendwo
schutz suchen
[Musik]
nun mit 110 kilometer pro stunde fähigen
über das gelände innerhalb von nur zehn
minuten steht alles unter wasser
das kann passieren wenn sich die
wetterlage rasante ändert
wenn ein sturm aufzieht gibt es nicht
nur auf wände sondern auch abwinde die
zu boden schießen und sich abflachen
wenn ausgerechnet an dieser stelle
jemand sitzt ist der wind
geschwindigkeiten von bis zu 160
kilometern pro stunde ausgesetzt
der wetterbericht hatte gewitter und
regen vorhergesagt aber mit so einem
schweren sturm mit hagel und windböen
hatte niemand gerechnet
fünf menschen werden durch
umherfliegende trümmer und zwei
einstürzende bühnen getötet und
insgesamt 70 verletzt
veranstalter sollten daraus die lehre
ziehen dass man gewitter die
vorhergesagt werden ernst nimmt gewitter
sind gefährlich
das festival wird vorzeitig abgebrochen
die staatsanwaltschaft nimmt
ermittlungen gegen die veranstalter auf
ich sehe kondensation bis zum boden
von einem gewaltigen gewitter zu einem
der schlimmsten tornado in der
geschichte der usa mai 2013 nahe
oklahoma city sturmjäger verfolgen eine
tritt der wolke die schnell wächst
siehst du sie hat den boden berührt sie
ist am boden am anfang ist der tornado
eine riesige super zelle
[Musik]
zuerst bildet sich eine wall cloud also
mauer wolke aus der ein kleiner tornado
trichter herausragt der den boden
berührt die wall cloud dreht sich und
rotiert immer schneller
noch sieht er ziemlich schwach und mager
aus doch daraus können sich wahre
monster entwickeln
trümmer fliegen herum und der tornado
wird immer größer innerhalb von nur drei
minuten erreichen die bühnen eine stärke
von 240 kilometer pro stunde der tornado
reist jetzt alles mit was in seinem weg
liegt
er ist jetzt richtig heftig und der wird
noch gewaltiger
[Musik]
die sturmjäger bleiben dem tornado auf
den fersen obwohl der rasend schnell
anwächst
ich habe ihn im bild
so nah dran zu sein ist lebensgefährlich
trümmer können weit aus dem zentrum des
tornados rausgeschleudert werden
viele leute glauben der tornado sei nur
am kondensationskeime fällig wo die
trümmer herum fliegen doch das windfeld
eines tornados ist viel größer man kann
auch weiter außen verletzt werden
fünf minuten nachdem der tornado
erstmals den boden berührt hat erreicht
er eine windstärke von fast 320
kilometer pro stunde
und er nimmt weiter fahrt auf das ist
tornado notstand nicht bloß eine warnung
aus einer schmalen trichter wolke ist
einem eso zyklone geworden jetzt haben
wir einen riesigen wedge tornado
es herrscht höchste tornado alarmstufe
das ding ist schon anderthalb kilometer
breit und reißt alles mit wie ein mixer
in der atmosphäre
und dieser mixa läuft im turbo modus
der tornado ist so gewaltig dass er
autos wie spielzeug durch die luft
wirbelt
er zerstört stromleitungen wirbelt
häuser autos und alles mögliche durch
die luft
es ist dunkel wie in der nacht dabei ist
es nachmittag nicht acht uhr abends und
das heulen des windes ist ohrenbetäubend
ist brutal strommasten werden
rausgerissen
[Musik]
nach nur neun minuten hat der tornado
geschwindigkeiten über 330 kilometer pro
stunde erreicht
im inneren des tornados gibt es gleich
mehrere wirbel kleinere sehr kräftige
trichter die um den haupt richter
rotieren typisch für einen tornado der
höchsten stufe
der tornado wütete fast 40 minuten und
zerstört die kleinstadt nur einen vorort
von oklahoma city
[Musik]
dieser tornado blieb sehr lange am boden
und er hat alles hinweg gefegt was auf
seinem weg lag
der tornado von nur forderte 24 menschen
leben davon neun kinder der präsident
stufte ihn als große katastrophe ein
über
1.150 häuser wurden zerstört der
wirtschaftliche schaden belief sich auf
zwei milliarden dollar
in oklahoma city sind mehr tornados
niedergegangen als in jeder anderen
großen us stadt die vororte
eingeschlossen kommt sie auf mehr als
150 tornados
13 mit windgeschwindigkeiten um die 300
kilometer pro stunde nur hat es
besonders hart getroffen der tornado von
2013 war der vierte in 15 jahren
kein platz auf erden ist für extreme
naturgewalten gefeiert im oktober 2010
wird arizona in den usa von einem
schweren gewitter heimgesucht doch es
ist kein gewöhnliches gewitter wie diese
bilder aus phoenix zeigen
sieht aus wie ein mörserangriff aber
tatsächlich ist das hagel der aus der
gewitterwolke kommt
wenn du vorher keine angst vorher gehört
ist dann sicher nach diesem video es
zeigt wie gewaltiger sein kann
er holt die blätter von den bäumen und
bei der größe der hagelkörner kann man
davon ausgehen dass er umstehende autos
ganz schön ramponiert
[Musik]
aber nicht nur autos und häuser werden
zerstört ist besteht lebensgefahr die
golfballgroßen hagelkörnern sind nicht
das einzige mitbringsel des gewitters
innerhalb von 15 minuten fallen fast 25
mm regen und der wind erreicht 110
kilometer pro stunde
es prasselt heftig runter diese massiven
niederschläge können leicht zu einer
sturzflut führen
das ist arizona mitten in der wüste
warum gibt es hier solche stürme nun ja
vom pazifik her oder dem golf der baja
california kommt eine menge feuchte luft
zu uns und die begünstigt gewitter
der großraum phoenix versinkt im chaos
in den straßen steht das wasser bis zu
einem halben meter hoch strommasten sind
umgeknickt und menschen sitzen den autos
fest die leute haben viel aufzuräumen
merkwürdig dass nicht noch mehr fenster
kaputt sind
diesem haus ist nicht viel passiert
andere familien hatten weniger glück 100
menschen verlieren ihr zuhause
20.000 haben keinen strom mehr
zeit für eine quizfrage zum thema hagel
die grenzregion von der brass colorado
und wyoming wird halo zu deutsch hagel
gasse genannt weil es dort
durchschnittlich an sieben bis neun
tagen im jahr hagelt
schwere hagelstürme gehen häufig hand in
hand mit sinnflutartigen regenfällen die
zu schweren sturzfluten führen können
genau das ist im mai 2015 im türkischen
izmir passiert
unmengen von wasser schießen durch die
straßen der 2,8 millionen statt die
menschen sind völlig unvorbereitet
unglaubliche bilder als hätte jemand ein
modell mit spielzeugautos gebaut man
fragt sich sind das echte autos wieder
vom wasser mitgerissen werden
das zeigt welche kraft wasser hat
lediglich 30 minuten dauerten die regen-
und hagelschauer in den nahen bergen die
diese enormen fluten ausgelöst haben man
sieht dass im bild nicht aber links ist
ein berghang über dem sich das gewitter
zusammen gebaut und abgerechnet hat
der regen ist am berg hängen geblieben
und hat sich dann seinen weg ins tal
gebannt
obwohl sturzfluten in izmir keine
seltenheit sind gibt es keine goalies
oder abflüsse das wasser steigt daher
immer weiter an
das wasser hat eine fließgeschwindigkeit
von über 30 kilometer pro stunde das ist
eine sehr sehr starke sturzflut
und nun zum texas pen händel und einem
seltsamen phänomen dass selbst experten
in erstaunen versetzt
als ich das video sah dachte ich erst da
sei eine frau kino fabrik explodiert
erst dachte ich das sei sand als ich das
sah dachte ich das sei schlamm der
darunter fließt
tatsächlich sind das erbsengroße
hagelkörner die sich zu riesigen wagen
angehäuft haben und dann weg fließen
unglaublich
der hagel stammt aus einer super zelle
die sich im april 2012 nahe el reno in
texas fünf stunden lang abregnet
unter bestimmten bedingungen trifft der
sturm auf kühle und feuchte luft so dass
ein hagelgewitter entsteht das
stundenlang über demselben gebiet
verharrt
obwohl es 27 grad warm ist ist
stellenweise bis zu ein meter hagel
nieder gegangen der sich mit heftigen
regengüssen vermischt
so kommt es zu einer sturzflut die
haare flut verwandelt dieses
ausgetrockneten bachbett in einen
reißenden fluss zum teil über vier meter
tief
eine äußerst gefährliche lage denn die
reißenden wassermassen haben sich mit
hagel und trümmern vermischt das ist das
eigentliche problem
auf den straßen türmen sich fast zwei
meter hohe hagelberge auf autos stecken
fest 18 stunden geht nichts mehr auf dem
highway
das ist festes eis kein schnee das liegt
den verkehr für längere zeit lang als
die ersten unwetter videos im internet
auftauchen glauben viele an einen scherz
doch noch tage später liegen dicke
eisklumpen aus hagelkörnern auf der
straße
solche dicken eisklumpen halten sich
eine ganze weile wenn genug eis auf
einem haufen liegt kühlt es auch die
wärmere luft darüber ab
die dinger wurden mit schneepflügen der
geräumt wahnsinn
februar 2013 im vatikan tritt papst
benedikt überraschend zurück der erste
rücktritt eines papstes in fast 600
jahren
stunden später schlägt ein blitz im
petersdom ein
was für ein zufall der papst tritt
zurück und im vatikan schlägt der blitz
ein das keine ironie ist plätze suchen
sich immer den höchsten punkt
der vatikan ist so konzipiert dass die
spitze des doms die umstehenden gebäude
überragt
das macht ihn zum idealen ziel für jeden
blitz der in den wolken entsteht
[Musik]
glücklicherweise bleibt die basilika
unversehrt der pressesprecher des
vatikans sieht darin jedoch keinen
hinweis auf ein göttliches zeichen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
zeit für einen test zum thema blitz
[Musik]
es gibt ja diese theorie dass ein blitz
nie zweimal an derselben stelle ein
schlägt das gegenteil ist der fall wenn
die verbindung einmal aufgebaut worden
ist wird sie leicht noch mal hergestellt
in das höchste objekt im umkreis schlägt
der blitz auch mehrfach ein
[Musik]
von süditalien nach südostasien
dezember 2014 an der südostküste
singapurs
[Musik]
singapur liegt nahe am äquator dort gibt
es häufig gewitter
[Musik]
die regenzeit hat gerade begonnen es
regnet fast täglich ein windsurfer hat
schutz gesucht und filmt das
heraufziehende gewitter gefährlich nah
an den bäumen
[Musik]
er hat so ein glück gehabt dass der
blitz in den baum vor ihm angeschlagen
ist und nicht direkt neben ihm
[Musik]
der baum hat den schlag abgefangen nicht
der mann
interessant ist dass der blitz durch den
ganzen stamm bis nach unten geht
aber der strom bleibt nicht im bau meer
fließt weiter in den boden wo er
gefährlich werden kann außerdem können
seiten blitze einen menschen verletzen
oder sogar töten
blitze können sich vom hauptkanal
abspalten und dich von der seite
erwischen
der blitz geht durch den baum durch und
über die wurzeln in den boden selbst
wenn du neben dem baum stehst kann der
stromschlag tödlich sein
der windsurfer hätte sich einen besseren
platz suchen können
sobald du den donner hörst solltest du
dahin gehen wo der blitz nicht
einschlagen kann etwa in ein auto aber
kein cabrio denn es sind nicht die
gummireifen die einen schützen sondern
die geschlossene karosserie sie leitet
den blitz nach unten und in den boden
gummireifen bringen nichts und man muss
sich auch nicht drinnen zusammen im auto
ist man sicher
[Musik]
mai 2014 im westen south dakota es
verfolgen sturmjäger einen hagelsturm
während der wagen an die seite fährt
streckt der fotograf seinen arm aus dem
autofenster um ein foto zu schießen
[Musik]
gott was war das überall fliegen teile
herum wissen sie was das ist das sind
stücke aus dem asphalt der blitzschlag
hat in asphalt zum explodieren gebracht
der blitz schlägt ins auto ein und fährt
durch den heraushängenden arm des sturm
jägers dann schießt er auf die straße
und reißt löcher in den asphalt
die leute fühlen sich oft sicher wenn
sie weiter weg sind doch noch rund 15
kilometer vom zentrum entfernt kann
einen der blitz treffen
er kommt quasi aus dem nichts hört sich
blöd an aber wenn es dort nichts wie
rein ins haus hier sieht man warum
[Musik]
dem sturmjäger wird das telefon aus der
hand gerissen auch der beifahrer spürt
den schlag das auto gibt den geist auf
glücklicherweise absorbiert die
karosserie den großteil der gefährlichen
elektrizität
das auto hat den männern das leben
gerettet denn es hat den großteil der
elektrischen ladung kassiert und die
insassen geschützt
[Musik]
der elektrische strom wird außen an der
karosserie abgeleitet der heraushängende
arm des sturm jägers bekommt nur einen
indirekten schlag da er den rahmen des
autos berührt auch ohne ihn zu berühren
wäre er ungeschützt gewesen
der junge mann spürt noch 24 stunden
später ein kribbeln im arm ansonsten
geht es ihm gut
und die moral von der geschicht bei
einem gewitter die arme im auto lassen
und wenn es blitzt alle fenster
geschlossen halten dann ist man sicher
wir können die elemente nicht
kontrollieren das zeigt die natur uns
immer wieder so auch im februar 2014 in
den italienischen alpen es ist früh am
morgen im südtiroler dorf plötzlich
rollt eine riesige lawine auf das dorf
zu
so etwas nennen wir nasse
schneebrettlawine sie kann entstehen
wenn auf älteren schnee regen fällt und
die schneedecke dadurch instabil wird
das eigengewicht der schneemasse führt
dazu dass sie auf einmal abbricht und
wie ein brett total rutscht so wie hier
als das gelände flacher wird verliert
die lawine an tempo dennoch wälzt sie
sich unerbittlich weiter zu tal und
schluckt alles was in ihrem weg liegt
sieht aus wie zeitlupe aber sie war so
langsam verrückt als würde sie sich im
schneckentempo bewegen
nassschneelawinen sind langsamer als
trocken schneelawinen höchstens 15 bis
30 kilometer pro stunde
[Musik]
diese art von lawinen führen extrem viel
geröll mit sich felsen eisbrocken und
den ganzen schnee nichts auf ihrem weg
wird verschont
[Musik]
die lawine kommt direkt auf das dorf zu
und rollt die straße entlang die
dorfbewohner wollen fliehen aber nur 25
von ihnen schaffen es mit dem auto und
dem hubschrauber die anderen bleiben
zurück
eine lawine die wie eingefrorene fluss
an deiner haustür vorbei fließt das war
haarscharf für das dorf das bergdorf
wird verschont die schneemassen ziehen
nur zentimeter an den häusern vorbei
hätte die lawine sich an einer stelle
einen anderen weg gesucht werden alle
häuser begraben worden
ein kurzes quiz zum thema lawinen
im februar 2008 macht eine kundin
satellit der nasa erstmals fotos von
aktiven lawinen auf dem mars von einer
über sieben kilometer hohen klippe nahe
dem nordpol des roten planeten lösen
sich vier lawinen aus eis und staub
[Musik]
april 2015 auf einer straße in
zentralrussland scheint die erde
lebendig zu werden und langsam alles zu
verschlingen
[Musik]
wir nennen das ehrt fließen die
langsamere variante eines erdrutsches
er fließen entsteht wenn der boden so
nass ist das eher gummiartig wird bei
gefälle kriegt er dann langsam aber mit
unglaublicher kraft voran
man kann es nicht stoppen es läuft wie
auf autopilot
alles wird verschluckt das ganze schiebt
sich über die straße
doch noch schlimmer wird es wenn
vorrückende erdmassen obendrein noch
brennen
ein lover fluss des qi low vulkans
nähert sich dem dorf barrois
das war eine schleichende katastrophe
die lava war nicht besonders schnell
sie bewegt sich nur drei bis fünf meter
pro stunde es ist kaum zu ertragen wie
langsam und unerbittlich diese heiße
lava auf die häuser zu kriegt
auf ihrem weg zerstört sie alles
wirklich alles
[Musik]
der lavastrom war bereits fünf monate
und 20 kilometer unterwegs bevor er hier
ankam
[Musik]
[Applaus]
anders als bei einem gewitter oder
sandsturm lässt sich die bewegung eines
lover stroms nicht vorhersagen er fließt
stets zum niedrigsten punkt
teile verhärten sich dabei und zwingen
die flüssige lava in eine andere
richtung
der strom ist einfach nicht vorhersehbar
dieses haus steht auf 60 cm hohen holz
stelzen als dilaver sie erreicht gerätes
in brand
solange die lava noch glüht hat sie eine
temperatur von 430 bis 480 grad celsius
alles was sie berührt fängt sofort feuer
genau das passiert hier mit dem haus
nach nur 45 minuten ist das haus
niedergebrannt auf hawaii rückt die
feuerwehr nicht aus wenn häuser von lava
in brand gesetzt werden man lässt sie
abbrennen in den folgenden vier monaten
krieg die lava weiter nach barrois
erster märz 2015 wird der störung für
inaktiv erklärt die gefahr für die
gemeinde ist gebannt doch der vulkan ist
weiterhin aktiv seit 1983 fließt
regelmäßig lava richtung ozean meist
aber durch unbewohntes gebiet
geschmolzener lava ist nicht das einzige
was tief aus der erde kommt
das ist ein schlammvulkan er entsteht
wenn durch einen riss im boden gase
freigesetzt werden und ton reicher
schlamm an die oberfläche steigt bei
einem starken ausbruch breitet er sich
kilometerweit aus und kann ganze dörfer
unter sich begraben
von vulkanen zu waldbränden
im oktober 2009 tobt in inzell bringen
mountains nahe los angeles ein riesiger
waldbrand
4000 bewohner müssen flüchten und beten
dass ihre häuser verschont bleiben
hohe temperaturen geringe
luftfeuchtigkeit und die berüchtigten
santa ana winde schüren das feuer
windstärken von 70 kilometer pro stunde
fachten die flammen innerhalb von
minuten an und als das feuer den hügel
erreicht wird es noch heftiger je
steiler der hügel desto schneller
schreitet das feuer voran
warme luft steigt auf und zieht den berg
hoch dadurch wird die darüberliegende
vegetation weiter erhitzt
1000 feuerwehrleute kämpfen tage lang
gegen die flammen weniger als 500 meter
vor der stadt können sie das feuer
eindämmen die häuser bleiben unversehrt
solche feier stürme überrollen riesige
gebiete und verwüsten alles auf ihrem
weg
es dauert eine ganze woche bis das feuer
gelöscht ist fast 30 quadratkilometer
werden verwüstet
[Musik]
was wissen sie über waldbrände
das feuer in prächtiges konnten es
forderte
1871 über 1200 menschenleben zwölfter
verboten verwüstet 2 milliarden bäume
auf einer fläche von 6000
quadratkilometer brannten nieder
im märz 2015 am ufer des sees in
sibirien
bauarbeiter trauen ihren augen kaum als
eine schnee wolke auf diese brücke zu
gast und sie nicht mal einer minute
verschluckt
sieht man nur wollten dann schneefall
und es kommt zum
white out effekt entsteht wenn ein
schneesturm mit heftigen windböen
anrückt auf den bildern ist zu sehen
dass der schneesturm scharf abgegrenzt
ist
wenn pro stunde 10 bis 20 cm schnee
herunterkommen ist das ziemlich
beeindruckend besonders wenn der sturm
länger anhält
wie im film nebel des grauens
der stumpf weg den fluss mit 70
kilometer pro stunde hinunter und
verfinstert den tag im zentrum des
sturms liegt die sichtweite fast bei
null zu
sehen wie sich diese weiße wand aus
wolken und schnee über das gebiet liegt
ist schon sehr beeindruckend
schnee ist nicht die einzige naturgewalt
die eine ganze stadt verschlingen kann
jedes jahr im märz und september wenn
die jahreszeiten sich ändern
verschwindet dubai in dichtem nebel bis
hoch zum siebzigsten stockwerk sogar das
höchste gebäude der welt der 830 meter
hohe burj khalifa ist kaum noch zu sehen
im april 2015 wird eine andere stadt
dunkel kreis zum teil fest hier los am
späten nachmittag rollt ein heftiger
sandsturm genannt hat bub auf sein haus
in weißrussland zu innerhalb von minuten
wird der tag zur nacht
in kürzester zeit wird es stockfinster
der sand in der atmosphäre verdunkelt
die gesamte stadt und entwickelt so eine
dicke schicht dass man meinen könnte er
sein 8
es ist doch erst nach mittag die luft
ist voller sand jeder atemzug fällt
schwer und schädigt die gesundheit die
100.000 einwohner der stadt verschanzen
sich in ihren häusern
es sieht aus wie eine mauer aus sand die
sich da in die stadt hinein schiebt die
sandwolken können über 3000 meter hoch
werden
vielleicht es dass der weltuntergang
wenn du so etwas erlebst glaubst du
wirklich die welt geht unter
ein heftiges gewitter treibt den hut
weiter an und wirbelt alles durch die
luft was ihm in die quere kommt
[Musik]
das sind starke gewitter mit abwenden
die ziemlich kalt sind
der abfallende wind war echt horizontal
aus
er nimmt alles mit was auf dem boden
herum liegt und wirbelt es durch die
gegend daher ist die luft so voller sand
und schmutz
die sonne es nicht mehr zu sehen
der sturm wütete 20 minuten lang stürzt
bäume um und beschädigte gebäude
verletzte gibt es jedoch nicht
[Musik]
14 april 1935 ein staubsturm mit
windstärken von 60 kilometer pro stunde
verdunkelt die ebenen östlich der rocky
mountains
es ist der schwerste einer ganzen reihe
von verheerenden stürmen die das von
dürre und wirtschaftskrise gebeutelte
gebiet heimsuchen der tag geht als
schwarzer sonntag in die geschichte ein
und das gebiet wurde als das bol staub
schüssel bekannt
einige der heftigsten staubstürme der
welt treten in der wüste afghanistans
auf im frühjahr 2013 werden soldaten in
einer militärbasis von diesem enormen
haben überraschend das
ist ein monster
ich habe noch nie einen boom erlebt der
frontal auf mich zukommt aber ich bin
mal von einem überrascht worden der von
hinten kam ich konnte keine 60
zentimeter weit gucken beängstigend eine
situation die diese männer jetzt live
und in farbe erleben
es liegt in der natur des menschen dass
man sich so etwas anschauen will aber
dann muss irgendwann der verstand
einsetzen und man sollte sich in
sicherheit bringen denn das ist ja keine
kleinigkeit die auf ihn zukommt sondern
eine 100 meter hohe wand aus sand wenn
man da rein gerät gute nacht
selbst mit der taschenlampe sehen die
männer so gut wie nichts sand und staub
machen das atmen zur qual
keiner will natürlich all diesen sand
und dreck aus der luft einatmen und man
sieht die hand vor augen nicht
in afghanistan zu tabus lästige
gewohnheit im winter gibt es
durchschnittlich 2 staubstürme im monat
im sommer sogar bis zu 6
extreme wetterphänomene sind gefährlich
aber
faszinierend je mehr die natur auf dreht
desto gebannt schauen wir hin
juni 2015 south dakota in den usa einen
fotografen gelingen außergewöhnliche
videoaufnahmen von der formation einer
super zelle
super zellen mutterschiffe wie auch
immer man sie nennt sind äußerst
spannende fotomotive
gigantische rotierendem iso zyklone sich
absenken der cloud und trichtern die
spielerisch aus ihnen heraus kommen an
einer stelle im video sieht man wie die
luft vom boden hoch gesagt wird das ist
die aufwärts- strömung die feucht-warme
luft die das gewitter speist und im
hintergrund sind regen und hagel
niederschlag zu sehen
super zellen haben heftige unwetter im
gepäck es kommt zu hagelschauern
stürmischen böen und sogar zu schweren
tornados
da konzentriert sich eine riesige menge
luft an einer stelle die energie
entspricht dem vielfachen einer
atombombe meistens können wir nicht
sehen wie sie sich entlädt aber wenn
doch gehört das zu den faszinierendsten
schauspielen der welt
von der super zelle zum super sturm
oktober 2012 eric an sam die fliegt über
die ostküste der usa und nimmt
schließlich kurs auf new york city ein
dokumentarfilmer in brooklyn filmt die
ankunft des sturms in der metropole
mann der bläst aber kräftig
ich kann verstehen dass die leute
hautnah miterleben wollen wie sich so
ein hurricane anfühlt wir meteorologen
wollen ja auch immer die kraft der natur
spüren das ist großartig aber diese
leute bringen sich selbst in gefahr
[Musik]
so etwas erlebt new york natürlich nicht
alle tage die leute genießen das
ereignis lehnen sich in den wind sie
ahnen nicht dass dies die vorboten einer
historischen sturmflut sind
sandy erreicht die küste bei flut
der steigende atlantik pegel und die
anschwellenden flüsse überschwemmen die
stadt
die sturmflut erreicht einen neuen
höchststand und sieben meter hohe
flutwellen wälzen sich auf new york zu
eine sturmflut unterscheidet sich von
herkömmlichen überschwemmungen denn
meerwasser kommt an land das zentrum von
manhattan stand buchstäblich unter
wasser die u bahn schächte liefen voll
autos versanken im wasser
die meisten leute unterschätzen die
sturmflut bei einem hurrikan
aber es kommen mehr menschen durch
wasser ums leben als durch den wind eine
sturmflut von vier metern ist eine menge
wasser wenn man da am falschen ort ist
überlegt man das nicht
obwohl es immer gefährlicher wird sind
noch viele menschen draußen unterwegs
man kann von umherfliegenden trümmern
getroffen werden und nachts in diesem
verdreckten wasser herum zu warten ist
keine gute idee
gullydeckel können weggeschwemmt werden
und man fällt in das loch oder eine
stromleitung ist umgeknickt die einem
einen tödlichen stromschlag versetzt
oder man wird vom hochwasser
eingeschlossen
der dokumentarfilmer hält seine kamera
auf manhattan und sieht plötzlich das
[Musik]
ein umspannwerk explodiert nachdem ein
schutzschalter durchgeknallt ist
hast du das gefilmt ja ich hab's im
kasten
als das salzwasser in die
sicherungskästen des umspannwerks
sickert gehen an der südspitze
manhattans die lichter aus
tagelang kein licht in lower manhattan
das war das war schon erstaunlich
die sturmflut verursachte mehr schäden
als der wind die wassermassen waren
überwältigend
nach drei tagen fließt der großteil des
wassers zurück in den hafen die
stromversorgung ist erst nach vier tagen
wieder intakt und bis alle u bahnen
wieder fahren vergehen fünf tage der
wirtschaftliche schaden wird auf 19
milliarden dollar geschätzt
sandy bekam einen besonderen spitznamen
wissen sie warum
der sturm kam um halloween herum da
trafen ein warmer harry kennen aus dem
süden und ein kalter zyklon aus der
arktis aufeinander und aus den zwei
verschiedenen elementen entstand ein
neuer super sturm
august 2012 nach phoenix arizona ein
gewitter zieht auf und bringt einen
riesigen sandsturm mit ein sturmjäger
fängt dessen schönheit in einem
zeitraffer film ein
ich liebe zeitrafferaufnahmen so kann
man wetter toll darstellen es ist schon
beeindruckend zu sehen wie sich die
sandwolke fortbewegt
wir befinden uns auf der interstate 10
nahe picacho peak den gefährlichsten
teil des arizona highway die gegend gilt
als staubigsten teil der usa regelmäßig
kommt es zu sandstürmen die oft schwere
verkehrsunfälle nach sich ziehen
das gesamte gebiet ist mit feinem sand
bedeckt wenn dann kalte abwinde auf den
boden treffen zum beispiel von einem
gewitter wird dieser ganze staub
aufgewirbelt
der staub stammt von brachliegenden
ackerflächen die in den 50er jahren
aufgegeben wurden und wieder zu wüste
geworden sind der staubige und
bewachsenem boden wird leicht weg
gewählt
der wind treibt alles vor sich her in
zeitlupe sieht das faszinierend aus ein
geradezu magische anblick
warum ich dieses video begeistert weil
es die kraft der natur zeigt mutter
natur ist wild und unkontrollierbar das
wird sie immer bleiben egal was wir tun
[Applaus]